Hi, everyone. I'm going to come in and said, I'm here to answer the internet.
Um.
This looks like a serial killer wrote it. And who did? This is the Zio.
This is someone. Wow. This is alarming. Um,
would you rather be drunk 24, seven or never get drunk ever again?
What about weed? No, it's like sober. Like you got no substance,
so I'm either only wasted or sober forever,
I would. Hmm. I guess never get drunk ever again,
but I would order painkillers from Canada.
Would you, is this your suicide note? I mean, what is
[inaudible] would you rather your internet search history go public or your sex
tape go viral?
I stand behind any sex tapes that I've made. If I'm going to be honest.
And my internet search history includes a lot of Googling,
inspirational quotes.
So I'm going to say a sex tape goes viral because it made Kim Kardashian rich,
and I need to retire. Would you date a guy knowing all of his exes are dead?
Did he kill them? How did they die?
I would love for my guys Xs to be dead. I wouldn't have to Google them all day.
Would you rather orgasm every time you hear all star by smash mouth or hear all
star every time you orgasm.
So every time you call them that that song comes on or like you walk around the
grocery store, it comes on and you come [inaudible]. Um,
I,
I don't want to be at the mercy of smash mouth in public.
Um, so I think I'd rather orgasm.
Every time I heard all star by smash mouth,
but then I would just have to cry, which I do already when I work as, um,
what's one thing a person can say or do that makes you immediately hate them,
um, film their workouts for Instagram. I mean, I'm more, um,
I can do this one. I can do this one watermelon all day.
Can use a gift card on a first date. Um.
Yeah. Thrifty I'm into it. Yeah.
Let's go have a drink at JC. Penny's it. Yes.
I li I mean, of course. I mean,
if it's your only option to get anything that might be a bigger
issue, but it's your only
[inaudible]. If you use a gift card or a first date,
that means you're the kind of person that people like enough to give gift cards
to
[inaudible] ignoring red flags. Okay.
Nobody can spin some negative behavior better than I can gift card on a first
date. Absolute Luli.
Don't put money into something that you don't know what's going to work.
Use that gift card. Good for you, thrifty. I like that.
Would you rather lose a leg or never be able to have sex? Again?
It depends on who it is having sex with is probably it, but I'd rather, um,
would you rather lose, am I allowed to with my one leg? Yeah.
I love that. He's just like, this is a joke. Just please make it just
like, you're like, I'm not I'm you. I feel married again.
Can you just answer the question? Um, Jesus, like,
why is it never ends with these? Um,
would you rather lose a leg or never have sex? Again?
I would rather lose my leg,
reattach my sex robots leg,
and then have sex so that I could be a cyborg. When you go to heaven,
you can only hang out with people who died the same way you died.
How are you trying to go out? Um,
I'm planning on drinking myself to death or falling off a cliff while
taking a selfie because that's very in right now. Would you,
would you have sex with your cousin to win Powerball?
Um, seven, seven 50 million.
Would you have sex with your cousin to win Powerball? Absolutely.
If your belly button was a real button and you could push it once a day to make
anything happen, what would it do?
It would instantly erase a girl's shirt.
If it said Rosie all day,
it would just turn into a regular shirt that people should wear.
Would you rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick or sit on a Dick
and eat a cake? I'd rather if it was my choice,
eat a cake shaped like a deck, but in this case,
I'm going to sit on a Dick and eat.